sean paul thank you uh so much for
coming in you can see from my smile how
happy i am uh to see you thank you for
the time sean paul you um so the album's
coming out and then you're you're about
to go on tour yeah but obviously we've
just had constantly because you
yeah that must have been really tough
was it it was scary
it was scary i think with all of us uh
you know everyone on earth was
challenged with with the information
that was being put in front of us and
also
uh things have changed since you know
i'm i'm going back on the road now and
seeing certain things that used to be a
staple to me in different territories
and that's now gone and you know it's
changed up either business-wise or or
just uh you know artistic wise there's
there's differences now and so
getting used to it
um
and and trying to remain as usual
rutical in terms of you know remember
how things were and and try to the good
things
i keep saying that and and bring back
those or try to instill that back for a
younger generation to be able to enjoy
that positivity and and and sean you've
had some incredible uh collaborations
with beyonce julippa rihanna busta
rhymes do you have any favorites and do
you have any least favorites
um i wouldn't say least favorites but
but uh you know there's probably some
songs that that uh
i i i felt like i could have gone better
in
um
[Music]
you know and and then i could tell you
my favorite first so let's top it my
favorite is rihanna um she came to
jamaica
she got to see how we
do in the club in the studio at the
beach at the bob marley museum it was
really cool for me to show someone that
because
most of the time i have to take a plane
to go and work with someone abroad or we
do it via internet yeah and so uh that
was cool to be able to show someone who
was becoming huge and popular at the
time how we do it in jamaica so she came
and spent some time with you rather than
you having to fly over all around the
world yeah so that's pretty special and
we didn't
at first think of doing work but then it
just came up and we're like yeah let's
do this and song was pretty big and it
was pretty cool so do you think you
might do some more with her
having a better she had her but she's
having a baby isn't she i know soon i'm
not sure and i haven't been in touch
with her for years but blessings to her
man and being very proud of her yeah
yeah and um another of your memorable
collaborations was baby boy with beyonce
a massive hit um and i read she was a
big fan of yours and she at the time
came to a lot of your shows
um do you think you'll ever have another
collaboration with her
uh i would love to she's a beautiful
artist uh amazing person
you know we have a spoke of that i've
been on different
uh tours and and and done crazy
different things
in the career since uh
so you know i would love to yeah uh on
the other hand like i have two songs
with sia all of a sudden now and she's
also a very
uh huge
talent how about this in terms of the
way
reggae and dancehall's been treated
because it's always been set aside a bit
hasn't it as its own genre it doesn't
get much play on mainstream uh
traditional radio but you've blasted
you've blasted through that partly
through these collaborations as well and
you've made it mainstream
and you've made it really widely
listened to you must be quite proud of
that i am um
you know there's a lot of artists that
are talented in my genre
and uh for me to be one of the people
who take it to a very big international
space
has been an important role in my life
and it's something i didn't plan for
yeah something i never thought in in my
wildest dreams i would be the guy
but when it started to happen i decided
to take that sense of responsibility up
instead of a feeling of pressure
um you know how am i going to beat
myself i can't i can only do
what i am no you know it's like training
for a race
if you're prepared for to do that time
then you will
uh so you know give it an extra push
every time and try
and so that's what i've been doing with
the music i've been just trying to
you know weigh the flag as as
strongly as i can and help the
youngsters to as i said before
see the positives that i came and
learned and knew and and try to give
them back as well and and sean
i mean look people know you for your
music but there's actually a lot more to
you than that
a lot more to you you are uh you have
your own foundation where you
do charitable work not just in jamaica
but around the world but you're also an
environmentalist and i wanted to talk to
you about that because
you and uh usain bolt talk about runners
another very famous jamaican you were
made ambassadors for climate change
initiative in the caribbean in 2018.
you went to
uh cop you went to the climate
conference in 2015 and you pulled
together the love song to the earth in
2015 a collaboration to raise awareness
for climate change and you got in paul
mccartney natasha bedenfield cheryl
crowe john vaughan jv fergie i'm not
even going through it had a great day
yeah i mean it's pretty impressive that
are you you did that in 2015
are you more or less hopeful now
about tackling climate change are things
getting better or do you think they're
getting worse
it's uh it's a question that that goes
uh for me to answer it goes way back
before
2015 for me that was when i was
aware of uh you know the certain
uh temperature
like arrangements or degrees of
carbon that each country is allowed so i
i kind of learned more technical stuff
about it but as a kid growing up in
jamaica
you're always told
uh you know climate change uh is
something that that in the future and i
was always like
maybe we'll never see that happen yeah
yeah um but i can tell you a personal
experience we have a beach in kingston
which is a very nice white sandy beach
that no
hotel organization has kind of captured
it's it's a legendary beach for
kingstonians to go to on a saturday or a
sunday eat some great seafood
um
and i remember going there my family
were great swimmers and so we swam for
the country and we also would take
saturday and sunday and go to the beach
and just hang out there all day
um and i remember as a kid this beach is
called hellshire beach
and it was at least 20 feet uh uh in
distance from where there were certain
shacks that were selling
some uh food and then a walk to the
beach
and further out you could walk out it
was really shallow it was a nice beach
for kids to be at
and then uh over the years i've seen
this big beach receding
and um
[Music]
it's very sad to say right now that
there's no more beach
and and it's shocking when i remember it
as a kid
that comes from
the climate changing and affecting our
coral reef yeah
um and our coral reef can't survive
which helps
to keep uh a natural
what can i say uh a a bridge between the
water and and its erosion
in the land so sure you cat you care
about it you can see it in front of your
eyes that the environment in jamaica and
that's just one beach yeah and i mean 90
percent of jamaica's gdp is produced on
the coastal zones right because it's
really important to ireland
do you see yourself stepping into this
space more and doing more
work music writing campaigning around
the environment i've been involved in
beach cleanups in kingston yeah uh you
know every year there's there's a crew
that goes out there and we kind of
publicize yeah yeah a lot of stuff
washes up on the beach um whether it be
from
you know passing ships
or from our own you know rivers it flows
into the sea
into our harbor and um we try to clean
it up every now and then so your fellow
musician beanie man said ahead of a
royal visit earlier this year to jamaica
that jamaicans didn't want prince
william in their country
he said
uh we're here controlled by the rich
british ruled by british law it's all
about the queen and the queen and this
and that but what are they doing for
jamaica they're not doing anything for
us
do you agree with that
oh you know
it's that's
something that i've not really put much
thought in honestly
my grandmother is from coventry
she was born in currency she grew up in
rugby
she met my grandfather here in the war
right after the war and moved to jamaica
so by the time i was born she was
already we were already independent from
62. i wasn't born until 73 telling my
age here but so it looks yeah all right
thank you but uh we we you know we
always had uh certain influences this
bus system was the same and over the
years it kind of deteriorated and we've
been feeling like
we're struggling so it's hard for me to
say some people
in it were protesting that they'd like a
formal apology for the rules for the
sort of role in uh slavery and they've
demanded repatriations
i mean do you
do you sort of think do you think that's
like in the past or you think that that
should be
so i was just about to say that but i
think i'd like to say you know i don't
live in the past yeah um i i don't feel
like i was the one that caused these
problems however
there are effects from it uh that still
affect us up to today
so it for me it's been a difficult i've
always been on the fence in terms of
i'm i feel like i am
you know uh
uptown kid in jamaica who has not got
much say in terms of how the people feel
but now i'm a i'm a entertainer that
waves the flag for the entire country
yeah yeah and so i must tell you the
people feel
a bit
left out
well you do wave the flag for the
country but also you wave the flag all
around the world and my final question i
actually got two is this when not if
when
you headline at glastonbury
which i'm confident we'll have yeah
right
i want to ask you uh what would you open
with would it be
burning
temperature
would it be get busy would it be let me
love you or would you invite beyonce
back to glastonbury to open with baby
boys
that's funny that's funny uh
um i could always invite her we'll see
if she'll come eh
but i i i like get busy it really gets
the crowd started i like get busy as
well
it was nice to get busy chatting today
uh finally one more and it's an
impossible question to answer so you can
pass on it what song do you wish you'd
written
what song do i wish i'd written yeah um
[Music]
um
strawberry fields
by
the beatles yeah awesome song it
actually is because when i was a kid i
liked the songs that hold your hand
better yeah i wanna hold you know it's
like very fast-paced
when i grew up more i was like here with
strawberry fields is awesome
i wish i was involved in something like
that maybe you could remix it hey
me and the great sir paul mccartney did
this love song to the earth i didn't get
to meet him but
uh i would love to do another joint with
him well hopefully he's watched this and
that's going to happen there
all right sean paul thanks so much
thanks for coming on good luck the album
and the tour and it was really nice to
talk to you i've had a lovely time see
you